yemen
it's home to the world's worst
humanitarian crisis
for years war disease and starvation
have plagued
pandemic is adding another layer of
misery
[Music]
for six long years a civil war has been
raging in yemen a country south of the
arabian peninsula
iranian-backed rebels called the houthis
have been taking on the government
backed by saudi arabia and it has been
brutal
saudi arabia supported by a coalition of
countries including the uk
usa and uae have been bombing yemen
since
2015.
[Music]
human rights organizations and
journalists who've been tracking the
conflict
say schools hospitals and homes have all
been hit and thousands of civilians have
been killed
about 30 of the country's infrastructure
has been destroyed by the bombing and
this has prompted accusations of war
crimes
shelling airstrikes and snipers hit
people going about their
daily lives often without warning in
areas where there's no active combat
going on
and creates the sense that there is no
safe place
for yemenis to hide a group of un
experts has also laid some of the blame
against the houthis they've accused them
of
indiscriminate shelling of planting
landmines which
maim and kill civilians and also of
recruiting children
into the conflict so why have both sides
invested
so much in this war
before 1990 yemen was actually two
countries
north yemen and south yemen eventually
they unified
but tensions remained
like tunisia egypt syria and libya in
2011
yemen was swept up in a wave of hope
known as the arab spring
yemen they were successful
but the replacement leader caused
divisions between the houthis in the
north
and the ousted president's new home of
saudi arabia
the conflict has destroyed vital
infrastructure
nearly a hundred thousand people have
been killed
about eighty percent of population
that's 24
million people are dependent on aid to
survive
and even that support is now at risk
because of global
economic pressures brought on by the
coronavirus pandemic
budgets are being slashed and essential
projects are being closed down
the average covert mortality rate around
the world is less than four percent
but in yemen it's estimated that nearly
30 percent of the people who contract
the virus
have died from it absolute chaos
here
[Music]
how does it reach everywhere else in the
world and not yemen
yemen also has amongst the worst testing
capabilities
in the world the war and conflict and
civility and
literacy and sovereignty
it's tough we hope we hope to another
organization to help us
saudi arabia had expectations this would
be a short war
but five years on there's no definitive
military outcome
and the yemenis are plunged further and
further into misery and suffering
but anything less than a negotiated
peace settlement will leave the country
further fragmented
yemen is facing the toughest times in
its history
with the world's attention diverted by
the challenges of a global pandemic
and its people they need all the help
they can get